120 kilometers off the coast of Lebanon
deep in the Mediterranean Sea government
ministers believe and hope there's an
economic Lifeline for the nearly
bankrupt state
the drilling rig Trans Ocean Barons has
arrived in an area known as block nine
where an international Consortium led by
total energies from France as well as
Italian oil giant any and state-owned
Qatar energy will begin the search for
gas and oil
we are optimistic because we're relying
on the assessment of companies that are
experienced and specialized in this
field they are optimistic about finding
reserves in Block nine but of course
we'll have to wait
exploration was initially delayed
because long time enemies Israel and
Lebanon failed to delianate their
Maritime border a settlement deal was
signed last year
and while there is potential there is
still no proven energy reserves it's
expected to take up to three months to
know whether Lebanon can become an
energy producer
since we are or the companies are
Drilling in deep sea water and for the
very we call it virgin land or the
frontier
sea that the chances of finding oil from
such an exploration do not exceed orgasm
hydrocarbons in general we're talking do
not exceed 20 this is a country in
political economic and financial turmoil
where State institutions and services
have all but collapsed it's also
governed by a political Elite blamed for
the corruption and mismanagement that
led to the crash their ability to
utilize potential wealth restore
investor confidence and ensure it
benefits the poor is being questioned
critics say those in power are
misleading the public by using the
author as
an economy they say in the best case
scenario block 9 will not give Lebanon
more than 8 billion dollars over the
course of 15 years a small fraction of
the country's debt that amounts to 35
billion dollars
but when drilling first happened in
Block 4 north of Beirut a few years ago
no viable amounts of gas and oil were
found that's why many say expectations
must be managed before declaring Lebanon
part of the club of hydrocarbon Nations
Beirut
foreign